staggering new numbers showing the
extent of the crisis at our southern
border according to customs and border
protection 171 thousand
immigrants were caught entering the
country illegally
just last month numbers not seen in
decades
and at the same time ice reporting a
sharp decrease
in deportations and arrests of
immigrants who are entering the u.s
illegally two lawmakers working across
the aisle on a bill
to address the problem congressman john
catko and henry cuer will be joining us
live in moments but we begin with
william laginess
he is live in los angeles for us hi
william well sandra three things at play
here
what how much taxpayers are paying to
house those
immigrants in a convention center and
hotels about eight hundred dollars a day
versus the seventy five dollars a day
for thousands of
empty beds and why those beds are empty
hhs has about thirteen thousand migrant
children in shelters right now
it also releases sixty percent of
families yet
ice has fifteen thousand empty beds
under contract
at seventy five dollars a day or about a
million dollars a day
meaning while beds go empty at ice
taxpayers spend
eight to ten million dollars a day for
children it could deport
but it won't the bite administration
also reduced ice arrests
by 65 percent and the agency cut
detentions because of the risk of covid
and judges
ordered the release of 3 700 inmates
1800 charged with or convicted of
homicide
assault child abuse domestic violence
rape
dui and sexual abuse of a child
that's who's in custody when you're
telling them to release them it's it's
not
some hapless individual who got uh
arrested by ice for a broken taillight
those are not the cases in custody it's
the most egregious cases that
is being forced to release
so i asked for that bed surplus ice says
it contracts in advance to get the best
price
hhs has refused to tell us how much it's
paying for those convention center
contracts in
san diego houston and dallas and maybe
long beach
and why it won't use those ice beds
sandra all right william
thank you